let's get into
uh today's speed round brought to you by
verizon 5g
built right all right chris what's more
likely
carson wentz is on the eagles in 2021 or
playing for another team well it's the
5g speed round mike okay and carson
wentz i'm going to go plays on another
team i'm going with another team i am i
just think this is not done yet the
eagles are playing their cards the right
way but i think ultimately the eagles
fans don't want carson wentz and if i'm
carson wentz i'm hearing that and i'm
going you know what i don't want you
either i'm out of here
i think that it is an effort to do a
matthew stafford trade
one that looks like a matthew straight
staff or trade but at the courts of
jared goff trade because they're
unloading 40 million in guaranteed money
over the next two years just like the
rams did yeah with jared goff this is a
big contract to unload off the books i
think the colts are going to be the
primary candidate to take him all right
what's more likely matthew stafford and
the rams win less than nine games or
jared goff and the lions it's still
weird to say that when more than seven
whoa okay um what's more likely man
stafford and the rams win less than nine
i i don't
but man the lion's more than seven i
can't get behind that either holy cow i
i i don't like either one of these
choices all right that's what makes it a
good i know i don't i can't go with the
lions winning more than seven yet so i
can't i just can't i don't see that no
so in the the rams in the nfc west okay
maybe i could see them going eight and
eight if the the experiment with
stafford doesn't work the right way i'll
pick that one
and they don't have brandon staley the
defensive coordinator so they haven't
changed they have it's gonna take some
time and there may not be much of an off
season program again this year reminder
this is today's speed round brought to
you by verizon 5g you going with that
right
yes yes yes because i'm not ready to
sign on for the lions winning more than
seven not with uh all due respect too
late for that not with jared goff all
right what's more likely tyreek hill is
held under 60 yards or travis kelsey is
held under 60 yards on sunday well
talking about speed rounds holy cow
tyreek hill holy crapola batman he can
run um i think that if i have to choose
either one there
i would go
i think with tyree kill being under 60.
okay if i have to choose one i don't
think either one i would expect both of
them to be a hundred but i would go with
hill just because
kelsey has an amazing
uh
cohesion with mahomes i couldn't figure
the word there
i i agree with you just because it's
going to be easier to take if they're
going to have any luck taking one of the
two guys away and maybe they take away
neither it's going to be easier to take
away hill than kelsey so i agree with
you if one of them is under 60 it's
going to be hill what's more likely tom
brady throws two or more interceptions
or gronk scores a touchdown
it's hard to say brady's gonna throw two
plus interceptions i'll go with gronk
scores a td i certainly could see that
then getting down there around then you
know anywhere inside the 15 a
play-action pass or something gronk
one-on-one with somebody uh i i could
see gronk scoring a td in this one bronc
shows up big in big spots he's going to
throw caution to win he had that huge
play in the super bowl a couple of years
ago wasn't a touchdown but it helped set
the stage for a 3-3 tie becoming a 13-3
win by the patriots what's more likely
patrick mahomes throws for 300 or more
yards or scores a rushing touchdown
what's more likely
i i could see both happening here um
i'm gonna go with 300 plus yards i am on
this one i mean you know got that got
hurt running the ball earlier in the
playoffs i would say let's not do that
against this buccaneers defense and
devin white and all that stuff let's
just let him throw the ball get it out
of his hands quick don't let that pass
rush be a thing and hey that pass game
is what got you here let's throw the
ball kansas city with devon white
lurking on the other side of the ball
i'm not taking my chances running the
football not today so i agree with you
it's more likely he'll throw for 300
mike or yard you know what's crazy
he only has two 300-yard playoff games
to this point of his career isn't that
funny like when you say that because
it's just 300 yards for him it's like a
walk in the park
but
it still doesn't matter because it's
like the quality of the completions it's
like okay yeah he's got you know 100
yards throwing and then all of a sudden
you're like whoa he's got 180 that was
one throw 80 yard touchdown boom and you
know it's oh okay now he's at 205 and
then whoa there's another 70 yard
touchdown he's at 280 i mean it's just
the um it's the quality of the
completions that's so impressive with
patrick mahomes he was north of 350 at
halftime of the last game against the
bucket he was on pace to obliterate the
norm van brocklin record from 1951 the
single game passing yardage record
is from 1951 chew on that while we take
a break and we will draft
uh mvps i think other than quarterbacks
mvp candidates for super bowl 55 we'll
be right back
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon 5g built right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports